الى التحليل الان مشاهدينا لهذا المقطع
اللواء فايز الدويري انت تابعت اذا معنا
هذا المقطع كما يقول القسام الجمعه اي
اننا نتحدث عن عمليه الامس وكانت
الاحصائيه امس عره جنود جنود وهنا في
المقطع يؤكد يعني من صور المقطع المقطع
يؤكد الاجهاز على كل الجنود الموجودين في
الموقع ناخذ قراءه اوليه في الرصد حس وكتب
في المقطع الرسد وتسلق هذه السواتر
الترابيه للوصول الى الموقع قبل ذلك اذا
سمحت لي هذه في منطقه جحر الديك نعم جحر
الديك متى وصلت قوات العدو وصلتها في
وصلتها في اليوم الاول قبل 47 يوم من
اللحظه التي اتحدث بها اذا مر على تواجد
قوات جيش الاحتلال في هذه المنطقه 47 يوم
وهذه المنطقه سن نشرح الفيديو جرى فيها ما
جرى اذا عندما نقول تستطيع قوات جيش
الاحتلال بسبب الكثافه الناريه واعداد
الاليات المقاتله اربعه فرق مدعمه بتسعه
الوي بما مجموعه تسعه فرق يستطيع الدخول
ولكن هل يسيطر هذه الاجابه بعد 47 يوم لا
تزال جحر الديك شوكه في خاصره جيش
الاحتلال الان الفيديو ماذا شاهدنا فيه
دعني اكمل دعني اكمل الفكره فكره جحر
الديك وهي اك اثر المناطق التي شهدت
تحصينات ليس فقط تمركز كما نشاهد سواتر
ترابيه نصب فيها حتى
هي يعني هذا الموقع الرئيسي للقياده في
تلك المنطقه هذا الموقع الرئيسي
للقياده تصريح القسام عن عشره الفيديو عرض
زاويه واحده من المشهد لم يعرض بقيه
الزوايا هذه الزاويه التي سنتحدث عنها
شاهدنا خمسه من مقاتلي القسام في لباس هم
البسيط
المتواضع حفاه لا يرتدون احذيه والبعض قد
يقول انه لا يوجد لديهم لا يوجد لديهم
يعني لديك تفسير لماذا تسلق تفسير هذا هذا
تسلل تسلل وصعد على سات رملي لو كان يرتدي
حذاء
لغاصاب
وغاس والفتره فتره امطار لاحظ مع اثار
الاقدام وبالتالي ستكون الحركه بطيئه ومعي
فاثر ان يتقدم حافي القدمين لينفذ المهمه
هذا المقر الرئيسي هذا المقر الرئيسي الان
وصلوا الى حافه الساتر اتخذوا الوضعيه
الحقيقيه ها هي الوضعيه الان عمليه الرصد
والمراقبه لاحظ هؤلاء الاعداد اذا تم عدهم
خمسه الان بداوا باطلاق قذيفه التي بي جي
ام هذا انا اتحدث هنا عن هذه خيمه من اصل
خيم الان تم اطلاق
ال النيران قذيفه تي بي جي اتبعت ب رمايه
من الاسلحه الاوتوماتيكيه تقدم اثنان من
المجموعه وصلوا الى
الخيمه قتل
الجندي تم سحب الجندي الى خارج الخيمه
وجدوا صعوبه في اخراج
ال السلاح بسبب مدى الحماله قاموا بنزع
الخوذه
ومن ثم اخذوا السلاح وعادوا ادراجهم هنا
تطرح عده تساؤلات الان عمليه الرصد التي
تمت لا يقوم فيها انسان عادي بهذه الوضعيه
اللي شاهدتها هو كان فقط يظهر منه مدى
الرؤيه مدى المراقبه فبالتالي كان حريصا
جدا على المفاجاه الرامي كان في وضعيه
محدده بالكاد كان القا فوق مستوى
الساتر اطلق القذيفه عصابت الهدف
تحرك بعض الاعضاء وصلوا ونفذوا المهمه
تساؤل المطروح لماذا لم ياخذوا الجثه معهم
الاجابه تحتمل اكثر من تفسير التفسير
الاول الظروف الميدانيه لو كنت انا ساحمل
هذا الجندي واحتفظ به
كجثة التاخير في عودتي لانه بالمؤ هناك رد
فعل سيتم الامر الاخر قد لا احتاجه لانه
لدي الكثير مخزونات وافره من اسرى احياء
وجثث اموات يعني تقصد انه ربما من اهداف
العم ليس من اهداف العمليه لا خطف ال لا
انا الان انا
الان هاجمت نفذت المهمه قتلت اوصلت
الرساله ليس لقائد الموقع لرئيس الوزراء
لوزير الدفاع لرئيس الاركان ساظهر لك في
الوقت الذي اشاء وبالطريقه التي اشاء
وانفذ عمليتي هذا يطلق عليه وندرسه كنا
ندرسه اثناء الخدمه ما يطلق عليه سمكه
الصحراء التي تظهر في
الوقت المجهول للعدو في الزمان المناسب
للمهاجم وفي المكان المناسب وتطبق مفهوم
الترويع والصدمه سمكه صحراء تطبق مفهوم
الترويع والصدمه لكن السؤال هؤلاء الخمسه
يا رب هؤلاء الخمسه الان العاجل انهم
انسحبوا جميعا بسلام عادوا بسلام وانهم
اجهزوا على عشره جنود الان نتحدث عن زاويه
من عشره زوايا او خمسه زوايا بغض النظر عن
التقسيم قد يكون العدد مؤكد اكثر من خمسه
كل مجموعه نفذت مهمه كل كل مهمه لها
اعدادها المخصصه لكن هذا هذه هذه الجماعه
ستعكس صوره عن الجماعات الاخرى السؤال من
قام بهذا العمل المتسلسل بهذا الاداء
المميز والوصول الى النتيجه وتحقيق
النتيجه هل هذا جاء عن حافه الطريق تم
جلبه عن حافه الطريق واكلت له المهمه ام
هناك عرق وجهد
وسهر لليالي واسابيع واشهر وسنوات من
الاعداد هذا اعداده منذ ان كان شابا يافعا
هكذا احلل تم اعداده اولا في البعد
العقدي بحيث يؤمن بان له قضيه والارض جزء
من العقيده هذه الارض المقدسه هو الان هو
الان يعد لتحقيق لتنفيذ مشروع لتنفيذ
مشروع تم اعداده عقديا تم اعداده بدنيا تم
اعداده مهاريا تم اعداده على مستوى
الجماعه الصغيره على مستوى
تفاعل الجماعه مع الجماعات الاخرى هؤلاء
الجماعه لا يمكن لجماعه ان تطلق النار دون
ان يكون تنسيق مع الاخرين لانه لو اطلق
النار قبل الوقت لكشف الجماعات الاخرى هل
استمعت الى اطلاق
نارق نار لا كان هناك كان هناك دليل واضح
احد الرماه انكف الى الخلف لماذا لانه كان
هناك نيران مقابله مجرد ان تم اطلاق التي
بي جي بدا رد الفعل من قبل جيش الاحتلال
ولكن مهاره المقاتل مهاره المقاتل ادت الى
ايقاع الخسائر وكان هناك عشره جنود تم
تصفيه العشره جنود تم اخذ السلاح عرضت
علينا سلاح واحد يبدو الجماعات الاخرى غير
لم يقوموا بعمليات التصوير لكن هذه عينه
كما يقال راندوم سامبل من العمليه الكليه
بعد انجاز همه عادوا وتركوا الجثه لان
ربما تحتاج هذه المهمه لسرعه قبل تدخل
الطائرات قلت لك هناك اكثر من تفسير
التفسير الاول الظروف الميدانيه انا اذا
اردت ان احمل لاحظ استغرقوا دقائق او
لحظات دعنا نقول اكثر دقه حتى تم سحبه من
داخل الخيمه الى خارج الخيمه وتم نزع
الخوذه واخذ السلاح الان هم في ظروف معركه
واشتباك وكانت كانت الرمايه سابقه على هذا
الحدث الان هو لو اراد ان يحمل هذه الجثه
الهامده لكلفتها نوع من الوقت وقد تفضي
الى قتله فبالتالي هو ليس بحاجته والتفسير
الاضافي ان لديه ما يكفي من هذه الجثث
وممن الاسرى والرهائن بغض النظر عن المسمى
وبالتالي المهم ان العمليه لا يمكن ان
يقوم بها الا نخبه النخب نخبه النخب كما
جرى بالامس استدراج كما قيل نخبه القوات
الاسرائيليه احد الانفاق وتم تصفيتهم مع
اداه الكشف معهم ما تحليلك للموت مقع وهذا
الموقع تجمع جنود خلف خطوط التوغل اي اننا
لسنا في محاوله صد لهجوم وانما التجمع
بالاساس انطلق منه قلت لك يبدو انها قياده
الموقع الرئيسي تقع على مقربه من السياج
في
بدايه وادي غزه مر على تواجد الجيش 47 يوم
هناك فيديو شهير سابق ظهر عندما ظهر مقاتل
القسام من بين الخيم وصور الخيم وكان ما
كان بعد ذلك اذا رغم انه هناك استهدافات
سابقه في هذه المنطقه لهذا السبب انا قلت
لك ان جحر الديك شوك في خاصره الاحتلال
وهي ترسل رساله مفادها تستطيع الدخول لكنك
لن تستطيع السيطره وستخرج كما خرجت الم
يقل اسحاق رابين يتمنى على الله ان يصحو
في الصباح ويجد البحر قد ابتلع غزه الم
يقم شارون باخلاء المستوطنين عنوه في عام
2005 اذا غزه عصيه وبالتالي غزه هي نقطه
انطلاق ضمن مسار طويل انت متابع ايضا لجحر
الديك من البدايه الى كم
القصف الذي تعرضت له المنطقه قبل ان تضع
جنود و خيام تجمع للقياده هنا ما الذي
شهدته المنطقه منطقه جحر الديك كيف تمكن
المقاوم
بعتادهم مسح المنطقه كما يع اولا اين هو
المقاتل هذا السؤال اين هو المقاتل
الاجابه سؤال يصعب الاجابه عليه والاجابه
التي ساطرحها لك هي نفس درجه الغموض انا
اطرح سؤال واجيب بنفس الدرجه من الغموض
اين هو المقاتل تحت الارض
في الانفاق ما هي الانفاق شبكه عنكبوتيه
كيف تصميمها لا احد يعرف ما هي اعماقها هل
هي طابق هل هي طابقين هل هي ثلاث هل
اعماقها اكثر من القنابل الارتجاجيه التي
يصل مداها الى 35 35 الى 40 متر رغم كل
هذا القصف لا تزال الانفاق موجوده لا يزال
المقاتل يظهر من بين الانفاق يخرج وهذه
منطقه مفتوحه
ليس كما نتحدث عن الشجاعيه او مخيم جباليه
يخرج من النفق يجد البيت المهدم انا لا
اقلل من جهد الاخرين لا بس لكل لكل لكل
عمليه ظروف الميدانيه وجميعهم مبدعين ضمن
الظروف التي يوضع فيها هذا المقاتل يخرج
في منطقه شبه
مفتوحه لاحظنا تقدمه تسلقه للساتر كان
مكشوفا وقد تكون لو هناك الطائره درون او
ما تسمى في في غزه الزنانه تاريخيا لو
كانت الزنانه موجوده في نفس الوقت لكشفهم
ولا استهدفتهم كما استهدفت الصحفي بالامس
ان ان يضع جيش الاحتلال مجموعه من الخيام
ومركز قياده في منطقه دون ان يتاكد تماما
من خلوها من الانفاق او فتحات
الانفاق الاجابه بسيطه في الفيديو السابق
ليس في هذا الفيديو الم يخرج المقاتل من
المساحه الداخليه بين الخيم الم تشاهد
الفيديو انا شاهدته خرج من بين من تحت
التصوير نعم نعم انا شاهدت انا شاهدت
الفيديو خرج ضمن الدائر الوسطى وقام
بتصوير المنطقه كامله اذا هناك طريقه
اعداد الانفاق لا انا لا اعرفها انا اعلق
على ما اشاهده ولكن هذه الانفاق معده
بطريقه وهذه الانفاق قد تكون فتحات مسممه
بطريقه معينه وتم وضع الرمال عليها واصبحت
جزء من امتداد هذه الرم مال لكن المقاتل
ياتي من مسار داخلي معروف يظهر في اللحظه
المناسبه ولكن بمنتهى المهاره الذي كان
نفذ تلك العمليه في الفيديو السابق كان
بمنتهى الروعه ظهر
تدريجيا بتاني بانات مطلقه وصور
واغلق وعاد وبعد ذلك تمت العمليه التي قتل
فيها على ما اعتقد 16 جندي في ذلك الوقت
هذا الفيديو من المفت انه الجمعه
الامس لنستمع ماذا قال ابو عبيده الناطق
العسكري باسم كتاب القسام وحيث اكد ان
خسائر قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي في
المعارك بغزه اكبر مما تعلنه اسرائيل وقال
ان شهادات مجاهدي القسام وما رصد خلال
المعارك يؤكد ان الخسائر الحقيقيه في
الجيش الاسرائيلي هي اضعاف المعلن عنها
مشيرا الى ان الاحتلال يبني حربه على
الكذب والتضليل
انما يعلن عنه جيش العدو رسميا من اعداد
للقتلى والاصابات هو غير حقيقي قطعا وان
شهادات ومشاهدات وروايات مجاهدينا في
قتلهم واجها ازهم على جنود العدو المشاه
توثق اضعاف هذا العدد المعلن من العدو
ناهيك عن اولئك الذين يقتلون ويصابون في
تدمير الاليات او اعطا بها وهذا امر متوقع
من العدو فكل حربه مبنيه على الكذب
والتضليل للعالم ولجمهوره
ولجنوكايين
باسم كتاب القسام ان مقاتلي الكتائب
احكموا نصب عدد من الكمائن لجنود الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي خلال الايام الخمسه الماضيه
وهاجموا من مسافه صفر وسمعوا اصواط
صرخاتهم
واستغاثات كما نفذ ذ مجاهدون على مدار
الايام الخمسه عددا كبيرا من الكمائن
المحكمه ضد قوات راجله للعدو في جباليا
والشيخ رضوان والشجاع والوسطى وخان يونس
تمثلت في استدراج قوات العدو او الكمون
لها في مبان رصد مجاهدون امكانيه دخول
العدو اليها ثم تفجير عبوات مضاده للافراد
ومهاجمه هذه القوات بالاسلحه الرشاشه
من مسافه قريبه وفي عدد من العمليات تم
استخدام القذائف المضاده للتحصينات وهدم
البنايات على رؤوس الجنود المحتلين وفي
جميع هذه العمليات اوقع مجاهدو عددا كبيرا
من القتلى والجرحى في صفوف قوات العدو
ويرصد مجاهدو باستمرار صرخات جنود العدو
واستغاثات بعد كل عمليه ورده الفعل
الهستيريه باطلاق الرصاص والقذائف على كل
شيء ودون هدف للتغطيه على حاله الرعب ولسح
ب جثه القتلى
والاصابات لنكمل اذا مشاهدينا مع هذا
الفيديو وفي التحليل اللواء فايز ابو
عبيده استمعت اليه بالامس واليوم هو يتحدث
عن اعداد من القتلى اضعاف ما يعلن الجيش
الاسرائيلي هنا توثيق لاحدى المعارك هل
يظهر مثل هذا الفيديو ان هنالك اعداد قتله
فعلا كبير تدور سواء في المناطق المفتوحه
او في حرب المدن والشوارع الضيقه يجب ان
اعود الى اكثر من فيديو هذا الفيديو تحدث
عن عشره الصور التي عرضت تحدثت او صورت
عمل مجموعه من خمسه افراد وانا قلت مرارا
ان جماعات العمل من ثلاثه الى خمسه هكذا
كنت اقرا نعم وحلل وبالتالي شاهدنا رقم
الثلاث وشاهدنا رقم الخمسه ولكن في حاله
ما كان هناك 25 في المستشفى الاندونيسي
على ما اذكر المدرسه
وعادت وفقدت شهيدا واحدا في تلك المعركه
انا تحدثت كثيرا قبل ان يصرح ابو عبيده
بهذا وقل الرقم الذي يقدمه الجيش
الاسرائيلي انا عادله رياضيه مبنيه على
نوع الاليات وعدد الجنود في هذه الاليه
اضرب في رقم 10 لماذا
ساذهب تحديدا في هذا في هذه الكلمه تحدث
عن اكثر من 100 اليه
خلال الخمس ايام الماضيه الان لو قلنا 100
اليه
واعتبرنا اعطاب وليس تدمير كامل لا لنعتبر
كالاتي ثلث دبابات
ثلث عربه النمر ثلث جار فات 12 10 ا
المتوسط ثمانيه لنفترض
30% تدمير
كلي الان 30 في 8 240 نذهب الى
النصف او لنقول
اصابه يعني تقع بين التدمير الكلي
والتعطيل الجزئي يكون الرقم اربعه عه في
33 هذا الرقم كم يكون
142 نذهب الى القسم الثالث كيف ما حسبناها
يرقى الرقم فوق 400 خلال الاسبوع كم
الاعتراف الجانب الاسرائيلي من بدايه
المعركه تحدث عن 100 جندي فقط حتى
المعادله الرياضيه الافتراضيه التي لا
ازال اعتمدها ومقتنع بها انسجمت مع
تصريحات ابو عبيده كان هناك توافق هو قال
اضف اضعاف الاضعاف من ثلاث الى تسعه قد
اكون تجاوزت الرقم ب اييه برقم واحد انما
الارقام يجب ان تكون ليس اقل من تسعه الى
10 اضعاف الاعلانات لناطق جيش الاحتلال
نحن لدينا مثال الان لاحدى المعارك وهي
عمليه هجوميه خلف خطوط التوغل لكن اذا ما
اردنا ان نضع الامور في سياقها هنالك
اعداد كبيره من القتلى ايضا الجيش برغم
اعلانه بالنسبه لل الاسرائيليين وحتى ايه
ال اوساط الاسرائيليه هي اعداد كبيره
تحديدا في لواء جولاني في معارك مثل
الشجاعيه يجري الحديث عنها عنها كثيرا ما
تفسيرك ل سقوط هذا العدد الكبير سواء في
مثل هذا الفيديو او في او في معارك اخرى
داخل الشجاعيه او مناطق مبنيه ما تفسيرك
لسقوط عدد كبير وكانهم يعني هذا الفيديو
يعطينا انطباع اذا كان العدد 10 من القتلى
وانسحبت القوه كامله سالمه وكان الجن جندي
لا يقاتل يعني هناك جمله من الاسباب اولا
دعنا ن نفرق بين نوعين من الخسائر التي
تقع اما خسائر تقع في الاليات او خسائر
تقع بوسائط
اخرى الحشوه الرعديه الحشوه
شواظ ت بيجيه على المباني القنص القتال
الفردي اذا هناك مسار موازي هنا نتحدث عن
الاصابات التي تنتج عن تدمير الاليات لكن
في المسار الموازي الارقام اللي في في
الخط الاخر هي اعلى من من الاليات لانه
الاشتباك من مسافه الصفر الان عندما دخلوا
لل الشجاعيه وشاهدنا الافلام في الشجاعيه
عندما دخلوا الشيخ رضوان عندما دخلوا توام
الكرامه خ بني سهيله تحدث ولا حرج كل كل
غزه كتله من النار وبالتالي هذه الخسائر
من المسافه صفر سيكون اي ثمنها بائر جدا
على قوات الاحتلال لماذا نعم انا لا انكر
ان هناك شهداء من القسام ارقامهم غير
معروفه لي ولا ابحث عن الاعداد لانه ليس
وقت الحديث عن ذلك و و الايام القادمه
ستكشف والقسام سيعلن لكن اقول في عمليات
الاشتباك القريب المدافع سيد الارض
المدافع الارض تقدمه اهل مكه ادرى بشعابها
يستخدم الارض بالطريقه المثلى يعرف الارض
بالسنتيمتر وبالتالي يخرج في الوقت
المناسب انا قلت سمكه صحراء وترويع وصدمه
يخرج في الوقت المناسب يؤدي وظيفته انسان
تم اعداده في كل مجالات الاعداد لهذا
السبب قد لا قد استخدم نفس المقاربه عندما
اقول العدو عليه انا قلت عليه ان علينا ان
نضرب الارقام التي يعلنها بعشره وان نقسم
الارقام التي يعلنها عن القسام على على ع
وبالتالي هذه ومره اخرى يظهر السؤال لماذا
العدو العدو يمت
بالنسبه لهؤلاء المقاتلين عدوهم يمتلك
تقنيه عاليه ويمتلك اسلحه ويمتلك دعم دولي
ويمتلك غطاء جوي اكثر من سبب اكثر من سبب
وساتي على بعض منها اولا هذا الجيش منذ
حرب ال 2006 لم يدخل في معارك حقيقيه
ومعارك مناطق
مبنيه رئيس الاركان
السابق وضع خطه لتطوير الجيش اطلق عليها
اسم خطه تنوفا وهذه الخطه كانت اساسها
الاعتماد على التكنولوجيا وتعزيزها
بالاسوار وبالتالي لم يتم اجراء تمارين
حقيقيه بالمستوى المطلوب لمواجهه عمليه
عسكريه تره لمستوى الاداء النقطه رقم
اثنين هناك ضعف قاتل لدى الجندي وضابط
الصف الاسرائيلي لهذا السبب الوجود القادم
في القدا في الامام ليس لانه وهو المميز
وليس لانه لا بسبب ضعف من دونه القاض على
المستويات الدنيا لا يملك الجراه ولا
القدره على اتخاذ القرار اعود الى الكمين
ثلا لما لما قلت القدر ركب على ثلاثه او
الكمين الذي مر بثلاثه مراحل اول مجموعه
وثاني مجموعه وثالث مجموعه من الذي تدخل
في المره الثالثه قاد الكتيبه قاد الكتيبه
قاد مجموعه من عده افراد لماذا لان من
دونه غير مؤهل لتنفيذ عمليه واعتبر انه هو
صاحب الخبره والمعرفه وكان قد القى كلمه
قبل هذا الحدث بعده ايام وانا شاهدت
الفيديو يتوعد ويهدد الشجاعيه وان له ثار
مع الشجاعيه اين اكتسب هذه الخبره هو
بالنسبه للضباط اخر معركه بريه خاض في غزه
مت الان الضباط تاهون في بعدين تاهون في
بعدين البعد الاك الاكاديمي النظري وبعد
الميدان التدريبي وبالتالي يفترض ان لديه
الخبره لكن ماذا ذا كانت النتيجه الذي قاد
المجموعه الاولى لا اعرف رتبته قد يكون
ملازم قتل هو ومجموعته جاء من هو اعلى منه
قد يكون قائد السريه قتل وفشل هو ومجموعته
من جاء بال الموجه الثالثه قائد الكتيبه
قتل هو وفشل وقتل هو وعدد من مجموعته اذا
هناك ترهل يعني هذا الجيش الذي كان يعتبر
الجيش الذي لا يقهر والجيش الاكثر اخلاقيه
ثبت انه جيش غير مؤهل لخوض حروب لا
متناظره هو كسب الحروب التقليديه ضد جيوش
عربيه لم تكن مستعده نقطه واحده ح حت حتى
لا ي دكتور دكتور حتى لا تضيع الفكره يعني
هذا يفتح لنا مجالا للحديث عما يعلنه
التحقيق المبدئي اليوم في الجيش
الاسرائيلي عن قتله ل المحتجزين وهم
يرفعون الرايه البيضاء وهم متجردين من
الملابس هكذا يقول التحقيق الم المبدئي
الاولي
ا وقال ان هؤلاء الجنود لم يتدربوا على
مثل هذا السيناريو اذا كانوا في المواجهات
المباشره او في او في في القتال من مسافه
صفر يخسرون بهذا العدد و واذا ما وجدوا
رهائن او حتى مدنيين يرفعون رايه بيضاء
ايضا ليست لديهم قواعد اشتباك على ماذا
تدربوا اذا يا سيدي هو الاصل ان يكون تدرب
لكن انا اقول لك ان هناك ضعف واضح جدا لدى
ضباط جيش الاحتلال من مستوى قائد كتيبه
فما دون لا بل اعلى من ذلك وقلت ذلك واكرر
حتى على مستوى المستوى الاعلى على مستوى
قائد اللواء وقائد الفرقه التخطيط لهذه
العمليه حجم القوه التي اعطيت لهم انا
اتحدث عن سته فرق هل تع هل تعرف ماذا تعني
سته فرق سته فرق تعني فيلين ماذا هل تعرف
شو ماذا يعني فيلق عمليه بربروسا اول من
دفعت فيلقي انقطعوا اكثر من 2500 ر في عمق
روسيا اذا هم يحاصروا قطاع
362 م مربع وكانت هذه النتائج لكن دعني
اشير فقط عندما تحدثت عن السته فرق حتى لا
يفهمني المشاهد خطا نعم كسب المعارك لكن
عندما كان هناك اعداد للجندي العربي في
بدايه حرب 73 كانت النتيجه معروفه وكيف
استسلموا في خط بارليف في معظم النقاط
الحسينه كان في اعداد ايضا الجندي
الاسرائيلي كانت هنالك مناورات في قبرص
مناورات في الجولان المحتل اقاموا مدن
شبيهه بغزه في في النقب اقاموا
اقام اقاموا مدينه ك للتدريب كامله
متكامله فيها شبكه انفاق
واستخدموا استفادوا من الخبرات البريطانيه
في ويلز واستخدموا مجموعه من الاليات
استخدموا التغريق والقنابل السامه
واستخدموا الروبوت واستخدموا الكلاب
والمتفجرات الهلاميه استخدموا كل ذلك لكن
هناك حرص على حياه وجبن وخوف هذ هؤلاء
عندما اطلقوا النار على ثلاثه هاربين
وبشرتهم تدل على انهم يهود يمكن من اصل
اوكراني او اصل ايرلندي بغض النظر ليست
بالسحن العربيه رغم ذلك اطلقوا عليهم
النار لماذا لانه لا يثق في شيء ويخاف من
اي شيء فكان من من من من منطلق الخوف ان
يكونوا من كتائب القسام اطلقوا النار لكن
هذه تقودني لنقطه اخرى كم طالبوا اهل غزه
من الشمال قطاع بالخروج الى الجنوب
ويطالبهم بحمل الرايات البيضاء اذا كان
عمل ذلك مع ثلاثه رهاءن كان يستغيث ويقول
له باللغه العبريه واطلق عليه النار كم
اطلق على كم
غزاوي فلسطيني حر شريف رجل وامراه وطفل كم
قتل تحت هذا تحت هذا البند والسبب هو في
الحاله الثانيه الحقد اولا والخوف ثانيا
وفي الحاله الاولى الخوف وال باسم الجيش
اليوم يتحدث ان هذا خطا ما جرى ما جرى من
اطلاق النار على محتجزين
ثلاثه كان خطا وخللا في قواعد
الاشتباك وان
الامر معيب هل كان ليكون ذلك لو انهم
ليسوا
رهاء اعتقد انه يعني الامر هو نتنياهو قال
يعني اكبر من ان يحتمل لكن هو يسال نفسه
هل جنديه هو الجندي مثالي صاحب الاخلاق
هال الجيش هو الجيش الاخلاقي هذا جيش منحل
جيش فوضوي جيش بني على العنصريه والحقد
والكراهيه ولكن الشيء الوحيد المؤكد انه
جندي
جبان هل كان جندي جبان في سبيل ان يدرع
الخطر عن نفسه قد يقتل اي اي كل من هو
امامه هل كان هنالك تركيز ايضا من
المبررات لسقوط عدد كبير من الجنود في كل
المواجهات وفي كل المناطق هل كان هنالك
تركيز على التقنيه والتجهيزات العسكريه
وسلاح الجو وفي المقابل استهانه بقدرات من
هم على الارض ويعرفون ادق التص هناك ج من
الاسباب يعني هذا يعودني الى يوم السابع
من اكتوبر الفشل الذي جرى كان فشلا
استخباراتيا عسكريا امنيا سياسيا بالمستوى
الاستراتيجي والعملياتي والتكتيكي
وبالتالي تحدثنا عنها كثيرا هذا الخلل لا
يزال موجود ولهذا خاصه في البعد
الاستخباري يضاف الى ذلك القسام فجا
الجميع فاجاني وفاجاه وفاجاه
وفاجاه فاجا الجيش الامريكي بصموده من كان
يتوقع ان القسام عده الاف من الشباب
بامكانات محدوده محاصرين من الشقيق
والصديق والقريب والبعيد من ال 2006
محاصرين
كانوا يعتمدوا على الانفاق تم تغريق
الانفاق وقطع سبل الحياه ورغم
ذلك 71 يوم وهو يق قاتل واداء الميداني في
تصاعد وفي ارتقاء النوعيه هذا فاجا الجميع
كف كيف ترصد هذا التصاعد ما يعني ما هي
مبررات هذا التصاعد بالنسبه لك اداره
المعركه هذا الفيديو الذي شاهدته هذا لو
لم يكن هناك عمليات استخباراتيه دقيقه جدا
معلومات موثقه هؤلاء لا يمكن ان يخرجوا
وعيونهم مغطاه حينما انتقلت الى الجنوب
المعركه شهدنا مشاهد اخرى نعم نعم نعم
الان هذا هذا الاعداد هذا الاعداد كان
يعلمه القسام والجهاد الاسلامي وبقيه
الفصائل درجه الصمود والقدره على القتال
والقدره على العفاء والقدره على التضحيه
هذه كانت خارج القواميس شكرا شكرا ذلك
اللواء فايز ز دويري